you've worked on Marvel and DC films
howdy the two universes differ in terms
of tone style and approach to
storytelling and what are some of the
challenges and opportunities that come
with working in each if you look at the
MCU there are very few superheroes the
you know there are very few traditional
superheroes there was never a guy with a
secret identity until Spider-Man in the
MCU their cap was turned into a soldier
even though he wears a mask and that's
all there was in DC you know Iron Man
doubted himself at the end of the first
Iron Man because they don't want to deal
with the secret identity stuff so there
is a bit more of a fantasy element to
DCU um because there are these Larger
than Life superheroes and you can't take
that you're not going to make I mean
people are gonna do whatever they're
going to do in the future but for me you
know there's Superman and Clark Kent
like they're two different characters
and you have to find a whale to deal
with them